qu'en est-il de jean luc lemoine at il
définitivement quitté la chaîne c'est
une question qui revient sans c'est
énormément non je suis récurent est
également à prévoir
vous voulez que j'y réponde en premier
vous voulez répondre pour nous il n'a
pas quitté la chaîne d'accord mais la
réalité ce qu'il avait un contrat qui
finissent et le 31 décembre chez vos
cyril h2o êtes donc vingt cinq contrats
et aujourd'hui on est en pourparlers
pour voir si rebondi chez sur ces 8
et si effectivement il fera ya un retour
mais c'est de l'ehpad de négo c'est
toujours comme ça on admirera se
terminer il faut un peu de temps qu'ils
prennent naissance il a il avait il
avait on l'a on lui avait proposé cet
été il avait il avait émis le souhait de
se quitter la table de tpm paix on va
dire la vérité on lui avait proposé de
venir faire les quatre tirs une fois par
semaine dans touche pas à mon poste
pour l'instant ça lui convenait pas il
voulait avoir son émission à lui ce
qu'on comprend tout à fait et ce qu'on a
compris ensemble voilà quand il nous l'a
demandé on s'est dit c'est assez
légitime
il a fait cinq ans avec moi plus eu un
an sur france 4
voilà il voulait sa propre émission on
aurait préféré ont dit toute la vérité
qu'ils fassent un petit peu de tpm peu
plus son émission il a préféré faire que
son émission donc on a signé avec lui un
contrat jusqu'en décembre
là jean luc lemoine vous savez que c'est
avant tout un ami il a fait un travail
exceptionnel avec nous et je l'aimais
énormément je vous le dis voilà c est
pour moi un des meilleurs qu'on ait eue
sur la chaîne
maintenant tu es pmp est le vaisseau
amiral de ses 8
on va pas se mentir et c'est vrai que on
avait très envie que jean luc lemoine
reste on a toujours envie qu'il reste
avec nous on aimerait qu'il revienne
dans la bande des pmp et travailler avec
lui sur d'autres projets parce que mine
de rien même pour tous ceux qui sont ici
et qui font un travail tous les jours et
qui pousse le vaisseau amiral tous les
jours et qui sont là et qui mouille le
maillot tous les jours et ben y en a
certains qui disent oui comme bien de
dire mathieu pourquoi jean luc n'est pas
là la semaine et il a des prime tout
seul
le vendredi soir non mais on se dit la
vérité donc mais qu'on vous a demandé en
plus de déprogrammer son calme
vous m'avez demandé un poste en direct
parce que l'actualité ici prêter s'y
prêter et et en même temps oui
évidemment la chaîne attachée à jean-luc
c'est quand même le présentateur de
guest match on a raflé 80
le présentateur de coupe ou pas couple
il en a fait car en bien sûr on a capté
son spectacle c'est un artiste qu'on
aime